allez on n'embauche pas pendant le
pillage
[Musique]
préfère les chiens les chats
les deux mois je que les chiens les
chats s'entendent bien
je suis pour la paix dans le monde
et a fermé la voiture la schl à la
cheville en taxi j'ai laissé ouvert
d'ailleurs il m'a appelé il m'a dit faut
le faire mais ce bébé je suis revenu
j'ai claqué la porte c'est fou non
à moi ça me troue le cul
moi aussi c'est dingue ouais hein
complètement j'avais un sens est ce que
c'est parce qu'on pourrait parler des
heures et c'est ça la vraie télé oui
c'est pas crever quand tu te réveilles
tu
moins que quand je me couche mais
je suis prêt
d'ailleurs ce matin ouais je me suis
levé j'ai pris mon petit déjeuner de
bouc j'avais la flemme de morat soir je
suis resté debout comme ça je suis
amoureux coucher après sa maîtrise le
truc que j'ai beau lire et relire
gressier way et étaient parents qu'ils
aillent au téléphone ah ouais ça on
appelle tous les jours il me demande me
dit alors ils ont fait rentrer du fuel
pour l'hiver dubois et tulle a retrouvé
sa personne
d'ailleurs je vais te demander parce que
c'est pas si tu te rappelles bien mais
la dernière fois la personne c'est toi
tu m'as dit une fois la perceuse ouais
j'suis pas bricoleur mais bon j'ai envie
de faire une perceuse ouais ouais je
vais vous percevrez je te les prêter
ouais c'est moi qui n'était pas la
mienne en plus c'était celle de tu crois
ce truc le truc à huy a rappelé noël m'a
pas rappelé elle sa part 1 contre moi
j'étais attendu notre foi devant le
restaurant et j'ai enlevé je suis en
temps restant j'ai dit je connais
thierry ardisson riz marié pas et alors
je suis ressorti comme quoi des fois
il est bon et intéressant intéressant
c'est très bon les corrections de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux